man:
The Recommendation gadgets
let visitors recommend
what they like,
find the most popular
content,
see who recommended it,
and learn more about them.
This feature is a bit
more advanced
and you will need to configure
multiple gadgets.
Start by setting up
the recommendation list.
You can change the header text,
number of items to show,
width, and color.
Then configure the buttons
by choosing the style, icon,
and button text.
Click "Generate code"
and copy the snippets
into the body of your HTML.
For advanced functionality
such as placing multiple buttons
on one page,
you can edit the code snippets
directly.
Go to google.com/friendconnect
to get started.